thank you
[Music]
there's a Polish streamer
uh named Sid nuke and cool name she just
got banned from twitch after doing this
thing and it is
they try to think of the worst thing the
worst this will probably be a little bit
worse whoa
she was using racial surgery
though huh because I feel like Polish
people are hardcore like when immigrants
are like refugees from the Syrian [__]
we're trying to come in all the other
countries like no and then Poland was
like let me get a fire hose and [__]
push him away like Poland's hardcore
Polish people are well she's using a
fire hose on her stream was she was she
harmful to another human
I mean just guess what because you'll
get it if you deductive reason to me
like not Syrian accents whoa okay maybe
it's not that
you read it activation there's Civil War
reenactments did she like [__] skin
somebody and murder somebody on Twitch
she was wearing someone's skin on Twitch
keep that thought in your mind and then
and then uh oh she beat up her pet she
ate somebody decide if this is worse
ready keep skinning a human and
murdering them so here she is uh doing a
stream of magnata she hits somebody with
her car yes
[Music]
she sees a cyclist and she accelerates
oh no oh
oh
I can't understand this
oh my God oh my God oh my gosh she's
streaming while driving and looking at
her phone what a [__] jerk off saying
is like there's dogs everywhere and then
just hits one I want to give her the
benefit of the doubt
she hit a rusty bicycle and it's just a
wheel spinning yeah I hope it was a we
did with you yeah hey points on
creativity I'm gonna go to cope with
this yeah dude I can't I can't be rusty
bicycles in Poland that maybe that's
what they call Rusty bicycles important
yeah you know
because we call wieners hot dogs yeah
yeah they're obviously not penises right
yeah I can't believe she hit a bike I'm
talking about sausages dude how sad bro
I hate hearing dogs Yelp like that bro
it was a bite yeah I mean spikes Yelp
like that so she was looking down
checking her taxes it was one second
looking on Instagram but she's like
streaming this like you know when people
do these driving streams but then she
also is looking at her phone at the same
time is driving yeah what kind of person
watches a driving stream
yeah let's think about this the camera
quality was insane though yeah holy [__]
have you guys just been on Twitch to see
all the stuff that they do uh do like I
would watch people play games but
there's a whole section of like ASMR or
like just people like living like IRL
and then they're just walking around I
could set up a camera and be like hey
guys I'm gonna wash dishes yeah you
really can and I can just set it up if
you got your fan base the IRL fan base
on Twitch is huge you might not have a
lot of views I'll get maybe two or three
sometimes it's better the more like odd
of a task it is depending it's your own
phone
there's something on your phone go on my
stream
yeah there's something
um kind of like what do you call it like
like uh
uh comforting about watching someone in
their home doing normal [__] when you're
lonely yeah oh I see I see I think like
during covet too like if you if you live
alone or you just [__] hate your
family and then you watch somebody
because I remember when I was streaming
I was like you know um I'm just gonna go
around and start doing chores and [__]
for no reason
but then I was like oh I can see how
that can happen too
yeah but also like
a stream where you hit a dog
is like really bad isn't it
I mean I'm sure she didn't caption that
before she did it is that oh my God yeah
not my best work there's gotta be like
well if this was in America I mean this
this is one of those moments where
suddenly like laws have to change or
like if you're caught like you know
twitch is no longer allowed to be
streamed while you're driving you know
what I mean like shit's gotta
that's that there's a kind of a dumb
part about this right I've been over
there at King Taco
I was getting a Mexican food and they
were [__] streaming no it was a uh it
was a truck and there's a stupid ass
like little white dog that was like
running around all over the place
already no one knows who the owner was
and then everyone's trying to get the
dog out of the street but they're just
zigzagging
and then you see this car come slam on
its brakes I think I saw the dog and
then it dragged the dog maybe a good
like 30 feet and you see patches of fur
oh and then the dog and then the car uh
drives off
and I was like oh [__] so I run up to
the dog and uh the dog was still moving
but you could see it sprained like the
fur was like sanded down the skull is
handed out so I grabbed the dog I
wrapped it in my hoodie and I took it to
um the animal shelter I mean a hospital
on Garfield and as I was bringing the
dog in like my hoodie was getting soaked
and there's like drops on the floor and
when I brought it on what can you guys
do and then the doctor said like the
only thing we could do is just put them
down so that they can like like not be
in pain yeah but I was like holy [__]
that was crazy it was just and the owner
probably will never even know what
happened to it yeah you know right yeah
no collar nothing
I don't know I was
I wasn't even a crazy season crazy man
you see that [__] all the time
one time I picked up a Pit Bull on my
Miata once and I was like there's people
walking down the street and I was like
what the [__]
yeah and I was and I was because it was
like a bite you no he came up to me it
was like chilling with me and I was like
it came up to the car they're not all I
opened the door and I hopped in and it
was like riding a shotgun with me with
the top down he's yours now that's how I
see it it was mine but I found the owner
and I gave it back oh thank you they
brought me ice cream in exchange oh
that's nice that's it yeah that was it
that's a story man that's still nice
that was a good story dude
you want another dog I miss having it
you guys you guys want to plug no you're
gonna get another one though well I'm
not in one space long enough to be a
good responsible dog owner yeah yeah
even though you can take the dog on the
airplane and everywhere like
I think I want more than one so then
that's like that's a lot dude I made a
part of your life to it yeah yeah
definitely but you want like a bigger
dog oh you don't want those little
accessory dogs I don't mind I like all
dogs but I I do think I have to have
multiple because then once we started
having like multiple dogs like around
it's so much easier you just sometimes
you just gotta feed them because they'll
take care of each other if you don't
have time to like play with them every
single day yeah especially if they have
a lot of energy and stuff yeah did it
happen to mention how many people were
like live streaming I mean or watching
her not a lot I don't think when I
looked up uh her numbers it wasn't super
high
so I don't think it was that many I
think like once the someone just must
have clipped it and then just it flew
around because that's just a that's just
trauma too you know like everybody just
randomly had to be witness to something
[__] I mean at least you didn't see
it but they should use these as an
example to not be looking at your phone
when you're dude that's a great example
well also the I think the main reason
why people are so pissed at her is
because like what she's saying what is
she saying it's a stupid dog like she
passes one in the beginning of the video
she just like passes it and then she
just says she says in you know polish or
whatever she says like Jesus how many
dogs are there and then she hits another
one oh so it's like that's why it's like
you clearly are like dude slow down
could have not hit a dog before she hit
it what was she doing she looks down she
looks super phone after knowing that
there's a ton of dogs on the street or
whatever like not to be a psychopath but
bring it bring it just bring it all the
way 100 one time I went on a hike right
[__] over there in Glendora and they
have these stupid ass [__] bunnies
little squirrels as as I was driving
this happens though yeah I know you're
driving right you see them all over the
place you drive extra slow yeah I'm like
all right cool extra slow and then I see
this bunny like go in the middle of the
road like this
look at me so I stop all right cool and
then it goes like this
it looks at me I'm like cool bounces off
the road perfect so I proceed to go
forward this [__] turns around
squished his ass I'm like yo cats be
doing that dude squirrels do that [__]
you dumb [__] oh my God you're driving
up and then they see you and then they
[__] like go into the car dude
they're over thickers bro do you think
squirrels are just dumb yes but also
just suicidal I don't know I was like I
saw him we made eye contact in their DNA
I'm going this way I was like dude good
directions
squirrels do I've done that to two
squirrels before cool okay the thing in
nature well there's nothing in nature
that goes like 40 miles per hour that
big right so I don't think they've
evolved to like deal with cars yeah I
was going fine
it'll probably be a long time bro I was
going like 10. all right it'll happen
too it was not a bunny but she killed
two but it will be like they're crossing
the street and I'm like okay I'm good
and then I'll accelerate and then
they'll run back into my car
wow [__] and I'm sick to my stomach and
I'm like now I I'm an accessory well not
really I'm the guy you are the guy the
squirrel should be charged as being an
accessory dude accessory to suicide
you were a witness and an accomplice
yeah yeah so I locked myself up too
guilty that happened to uh me Mike and
Victor one time too at UCI I don't know
if you ever came over to an apartment
you saw this little um this little bunny
statue we had we named it Enoch because
of a [__] death that we saw at UCI so
there's always rabbits at [__] UCLA's
bunnies everywhere right yeah and then
we were just walking back to our dorm
one time and then there's a speed bumps
on like East Pelton center right just
like the inside like Road of the campus
and uh bunny was going by and we're like
nah dude there's no way you know they're
just running straight for this car this
cars go mad slow too like no dude
there's no way it's right on top of the
speed bump as the [__] car goes on
the speed bump and it's slow and you
know you just witness death in slow
motion you know what I mean it's just
like I can see festivals and [__] now
um but it [__] squished this thing
all the way to the point where like it's
Gus flew and me and my convict we ran
all the way up to the scene and his
heart was on the floor still beating so
we just saw a beating heart
you know and then it just slowly like
slowed down and then just [__] stop
oh my and from that day forward we named
that [__] rapid Enoch and then we put
a little Stone statue on our team why
did you do anything you should have
stopped it I prayed
yeah I can't believe you didn't do
anything oh god dude you you suicided
two two squirrels I did that's crazy the
guts fly out like someone was squeezing
a ketchup bottle dude it was like that
title of this video [__] dog gets
skinned to the point where it's shaved
down and sandpapered the [__] brains
I saw the brain yeah that was crazy all
right guys is there anything else you
guys want to talk about before we end
this video can we go back to the UN
alive squirrels by your hand that's not
that bad compared to the upstairs
cool book
good
[Music]